[MUSIC PLAYING]
[MUSIC - EDWARD ELGAR, "POMP AND
CIRCUMSTANCE"]
PRESENTER: Ladies and
gentlemen, the guests of honor,
the class of 1994.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GRAY: The corporation and the
faculty of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
are now declared
convened together
with this assembly
on this glorious
morning in Cambridge
on the occasion of
the commencement
exercises of the Institute for
the conferring of its degrees.
The stage assembly and
audience will please rise
and join Professor Ellen Harris,
associate provost for the arts,
in the singing of one verse
of "The Star-Spangled Banner,"
to be followed by the invocation
by the Reverent Scott Paradise.
[MUSIC - "THE STAR SPANGLED
BANNER"]
HARRIS: [SINGING]
O, say, can you
see, by the dawn's early
light, what so proudly
we hailed at the twilight's
last gleaming, whose
broad stripes and bright stars,
through the perilous fight o'er
the ramparts we watched
were so gallantly streaming?
And the rocket's red glare,
the bombs bursting in air,
gave proof through the night
that our flag was still there.
O, say does that star-spangled
banner yet wave o'er
the land of the free and
the home of the brave.
[APPLAUSE]
PARADISE: Let us pray.
Oh, holy God, creator
of all things.
We offer thanks with hearts
overflowing for the privilege
to live and work in this place,
for the opportunity to learn,
for the experiences
of testing, which
try us as silver is tried.
For friends and mentors,
for the excitement of ideas,
the joy of discovery.
Oh, God of justice and
love, we find the world
shaped not only by
human achievements,
but also by human failures.
We have ended the Cold War and
reduced the nuclear threat.
But we see violence proliferate
in families, on the streets,
in oppressive regimes, and in
civil wars around the globe.
We have created great
wealth, but we have
acquiesced to great poverty.
We have awakened as a nation
to the environmental crisis,
but we have been unwilling
to make the changes
necessary to resolve it.
Oh, God, giver of life and
hope, we commit ourselves
to a renewed sense of vocation.
May we realize that
even the smallest
deeds of love and justice and
generosity can change history.
May we learn to risk speaking
the truth when evil is
being done and all are silent.
May we work less on the
problems of the powerful
and the prosperous
and more on the needs
of the poorest, the weakest,
and the most vulnerable
of our brothers and sisters.
May we together blaze
a path toward a world
at peace with itself and
reconciled with the earth.
Oh, God, our companion on
the way, be with us as we
go forth from this place.
Give us hope for the future
and joy in our hearts.
Amen.
Please be seated.
GRAY: I'm pleased to welcome
to the platform this morning
the honorable Kenneth E. Reeves,
mayor of the city of Cambridge.
[APPLAUSE]
It is my privilege to
welcome his highness, The Aga
Khan, spiritual leader of
the Shia Ismalli Muslims.
His highness The Aga Khan
will now present the address.
[APPLAUSE]
KHAN: President Vest,
members of the corporation
of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology,
distinguished members of
the faculty, Mayor Reeves,
happy graduates,
even happier parents,
and others gathered
here today, I
am pleased and honored to
be with you this morning.
MIT has shown a
standard of excellence
in education and research
that sets a benchmark
for universities everywhere.
You who have been at
the Institute for years
may be excused if you
take this in stride.
But for me, coming here for the
first time in several years,
the energy of the
place is palpable.
Actually, my reaction
is somewhat personal.
When as a young man I began
to think about colleges,
MIT was my first choice.
In the end, I acceded to the
advice of my grandfather, who
favored Harvard.
[LAUGHTER]
In fact, I didn't even apply
anywhere other than MIT.
And MIT accepted me on
the basis of my grades.
They didn't even ask me to
take an examination, which
is good, because I could hardly
understand written English.
When my grandfather told me I
shouldn't didn't enroll here,
I was devastated.
That really put the kibosh
on my plans to study science.
You see, I learned
Harvard English.
[LAUGHTER]
Education has been important
to my family for a long time.
My forefathers founded
Al-Azhar University in Cairo
some 1,000 years ago at the
time of the Fatimid Caliphate
in Egypt.
Discovery of knowledge
was seen by those founders
as an embodiment of
religious faith and faith,
as reinforced by knowledge
of workings of the creator's
physical world.
The form of universities has
changed over those 1,000 years.
But that reciprocity
between faith and knowledge
remains a source of strength.
MIT has changed also
over its 130 years.
This university was
initially designed
to meet the needs of society in
a newly industrialized world.
As the world and
its needs evolved,
so has MIT's curriculum.
Steadily, the emphasis on
social sciences and humanities
has expanded as the Institute
has recognized increasingly
that the range of
technologies that
are needed to solve
societal problems
goes far beyond
those of engineering
and natural sciences.
The increased richness
of education results
in an increasingly
versatile set of graduates.
As I look out over those
today who are here,
I see that MIT has
changed in other ways.
The great continents
of the world
are now represented
in your student body
and in your faculty.
So too are the great
religions of the world.
MIT seems prepared to take
advantage of excellence
from all quarters.
A fact that is sure to
reinforce the Institute's
future strength.
When I was thinking
about the theme
that I should choose
for this talk,
I considered first that
commencements are occasions
to reflect on general
truths, truths
that will retain their validity
over the course of your lives
and over a wide range of
intellectual interests
that you graduates embody.
But how is that
search for generality
to be squared with the very
particular point in time
that today represents?
You and I are here
in a real sense
only because 1994
finds MIT and the world
at distinctive stages
of their evolution.
Still, the particular
can provide insight
into the general.
So my comments today will
draw on the particular
in the hope of saying something
of value about the general.
I shall talk today
about encounters,
encounters when two people
meet or two particles or two
cultures.
In that crucial
moment of interaction,
the results of an
encounter are determined.
In the simplest of encounters,
say, with two billiard balls,
the outcome is a predictable
result of position, velocity,
and mass.
But the encounters that interest
me most are not so simple.
In the encounters of
people and cultures,
much depends on the path that
each has taken to that point.
These are not
stochastic processes.
The subjects have histories.
The encounter has complexity
and rich dimensionality.
The result of an encounter
between two people
or between two
cultures is shaped
by the assumptions of each,
by their respective goals,
and perhaps, more directly
relevant to a university,
by the repertoire of responses
that each has learned.
Encounters, therefore, have
aspects of both the general
and the specific.
What makes our current
time distinctive
are the new combinations
of people and cultures
that are participating
in these encounters.
Two ongoing social
and political changes
illustrate the reasons for
these new combinations.
The first is the
collapse of communism
in the USSR and Eastern Europe.
You graduates may feel that
you've been at MIT forever.
But it really is remarkable
that the overturning
of the communist world has
occurred since most of you
started your studies here.
You go out into a world
where the rules are
different from those that
held when you entered.
Colonialism is moribund.
No longer is it enough
to decide whether one
is aligned with communism or
capitalism in a bipolar world.
Now a full range of
complicated choices
is opened up to people in the
developed and the developing
world alike.
A massive break on
change has been released.
The potential for creative
action, creative encounters,
is now much enhanced.
This change is a work
in progress, however.
The potential of
the moment must be
seized, for
conditions for change
may not always be so propitious.
There is the real possibility
that the Soviet Union
may reconstitute itself if
the social upheaval that
accompanies political
disintegration
and economic reform
is allowed to become
less tolerable than the
strictures of a totalitarian
state.
While these shocks reverberate
from the ex-communist bloc,
profound changes of a
very different character
are to be found in
the Islamic world.
Here the changes are in
both perception and reality.
And both of them are
works in progress, too.
The Islamic world
is remarkably poorly
understood by the West,
almost terra incognita.
Even now, one sees
pervasive images in the West
that caricature Muslims
as either oil sheiks
or unruly fundamentalists.
The Islamic world is, in fact,
a rich and changing tapestry
which the West would
do well to understand.
The economic power
of the Islamic world
is increasing, not so much
because of Middle Eastern oil,
but because of the rapid
growth of newly industrializing
countries like
Malaysia and Indonesia.
Its population is increasing and
already represents nearly one
quarter of the world's total.
It is remarkably diverse,
ethnically, economically,
politically, and in
its interpretations
of its own faith.
The Muslim world
can no longer be
thought of as a subset
of the developing world.
Islam is well represented in the
United States, Canada, United
Kingdom, and Western Europe.
And that presence is growing.
The religious diversity of Islam
is important and misunderstood
by most non-Muslims.
This is not the forum to go
into the multiple reasons
for this misunderstanding.
But for many in the
West, the first awareness
that there were two major
branches of Islam, Shia
and Sunni, only came with
the Iranian revolution.
That represents a
superficiality of understanding
that would be as though we
Muslims only just learned
that there were two branches
of Christianity, Protestant
and Catholic, and
had no understanding
of the Reformation, the
authority of the church,
or the ideas that led
to the proliferation
of Protestant sects in
the 16th and 17th century.
Or as though we thought
that most Americans were
Branch Davidians.
In the face of such
lack of knowledge,
about one quarter of
the world's population,
one may reasonably ask what
the role of the university
is in setting this straight.
It seems clear to me that
at the most basic level,
the university is responsible
for helping its students
to learn not only the
simplifying principles
that the various learned
disciplines found
useful in understanding
our world,
but also the rich complexity
of history and language
and culture that make
real-life problems
interesting and difficult.
MIT now teaches both of these
lessons well and vigorously.
But it seems not
always to have done so.
Indeed, I am told that at
the opening of MIT in 1865,
one local newspaper reported
with a note of triumph
that the creation of
MIT, quote, "sealed
the fate of that system by
which our youth waste the best
portion of student life in
burrowing into the grammars
and dictionaries of races less
enlightened than their own,"
unquote.
MIT has clearly come
around to thinking
that those less enlightened
races have something to teach.
And that teaching
helps the university
fulfill its potential.
I would argue, however, that
the university's potential
is met not just in
developing the intelligence
of its students but also in
bringing them to understand
the importance of engaging
themselves in solving
the problems of the world.
The great political and
social changes around us
are creating
opportunities for service
that promise to be deeply
rewarding to persons
with the engaged
intelligence to be
successful at important
but difficult work.
Let me take one example to
illustrate the challenging
encounters to which
today's graduates might
apply their intelligence.
Tajikistan is a
mountainous country
in Central Asia of five million
people, more than 90% Muslim.
As a republic in the
former Soviet Union
bordering China
and Afghanistan, it
had a strategic importance that
dwarfed its natural resources.
The Soviet Union,
therefore, invested heavily
in Tajikistan, building
roads and power stations,
supplementing food
supplies and equipment,
developing the education
and health systems.
The result was a highly
educated, sophisticated,
but largely rural
population that
managed its affairs well at
home by the rules of the game
at that time and provided
well-developed human resources
for export to other parts
of the Soviet Union.
With the fall of
the Soviet Union,
things changed for Tajikistan.
Subsidies, which had provided
most of the republic's budget,
and for the remoter parts,
80% of the food supply,
were cut off.
The result has been hunger,
shortages of fuel and clothing,
and deep uncertainty
about the future.
Long suppressed ethnic tensions
between indigenous tajiks,
neighboring Uzbeks and Kyrgyz,
and immigrant Russians,
amongst others,
became more evident
as groups jostled for
political and economic control.
Religion emerged
from private houses,
where it had been practiced
covertly for 60 years,
to become a manifest force.
Tajikistan has become
the focus of one
of the most interesting
encounters of the day.
It is here and in
other Central Asian
republics that the three great
cultures encounter each other--
the communist world, the Muslim
world, and the Western world.
It is here that
those three cultures
could forge a success that
would contrast starkly
with the brutal
failure in Bosnia.
The result of the
encounter in Tajikistan
may determine much about the way
history unfolds over the coming
decades.
So it is worth thinking
a bit about the stance
that each of these
cultures might
take in preparing
for this encounter.
That thought might
lead one to ask
what it would take for
this or any encounter
to be constructive.
I suggest that there are four
prerequisites for success.
For each of the
cultures, the result
should first draw on
its strengths and second
be consistent with its goals.
Third, the result should be
a sustainable improvement
in the current situation.
And fourth, the transition
should be humane.
Each of these three
cultures has something
to bring to the solution of
the problems of Tajikistan.
The West has many strengths.
But prominent among them
are science and democracy
with their public mechanisms
for self-correction
and also private institutions,
liberal economics,
and their recognition of
fundamental human rights.
The Muslim world offers deep
roots in a system of values,
emphasizing service, charity, a
sense of common responsibility,
and denying what it sees
to be the false dichotomy
between religious
and secular lives.
The ex-communist world,
although it failed economically,
made important investments
in social welfare
with particular emphasis
on the status of women
and was able to achieve in
Tajikistan impressive social
cohesion.
Just how to combine
these competencies,
to solve Tajikistan's
problems, is not clear.
But if the outcome
is to be sustainable,
it seems necessary to
concentrate resources
on the development of
private institutions,
of accountable
public institutions,
and of human potential.
But how to get
from here to there
without inflicting cruel damage
on the people already buffeted
by shortages and change?
Again, the way is
not entirely clear.
But one should strive to
retain the powerful ties
of mutual support
that in different ways
bind individuals together in
Muslim and communist societies.
And one should see that the
impressive gains in health
and education are not
lost in the transition,
for it would be
unconscionable to allow,
for example, the
equality of men and women
that has been achieved in
Tajikistan over the last 60
years to be erased in the
transition to a market economy.
These are the
prerequisites that I
hope the representatives of
these three important cultures
will keep in mind as they
have their own encounter
over Tajikistan.
If the encounter of the
Muslim world, the West,
and the ex-communist world takes
account of the need for each
to draw on its own strengths,
to be consistent with its goals,
to strive for a sustainable,
improved outcome,
and to ensure a
humane transition,
then the encounter have been as
successful as it is important.
Indeed, the importance
of Tajikistan
has, if anything
increased in recent years
as events in
neighboring countries
continue to remind us.
Turning back to
today's graduates,
I hope that these four
prerequisites applied equally
to the encounter that you
are just completing with MIT.
Knowing the quality of
faculty and students here,
I have no doubt
that the encounter
between you and the
faculty has drawn
on your respective strengths.
I hope each of you kept
consistent with your goals,
even as they may have
evolved over your time here.
The quality and
sustainability of the outcome
will be determined over
the course of your lives.
But reading the smiles
amongst the graduates,
I judge that the transition,
your time at MIT,
must have been tolerably humane.
In conclusion, I would recall
the words of former MIT
President James
Killian Jr, quote,
"We need better linkages
between science and humanities
with the object of fusing the
two into a broad humanism that
rests upon both science
and the liberal arts
and that does not weaken either.
We need bifocal vision to thread
our way among the problems
of modern society," unquote.
That need to use the power
of complementary academic
disciplines remains true today.
What is now clear
is the need also
to draw on the wisdom
of different cultures
in solving those problems.
Thank you, and please
accept my best wishes
for a lifetime of
constructive encounters.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
GRAY: Your highness,
thank you very
much for your insightful
and challenging comments
on encounters
human and cultural.
And thank you so much for
gracing this commencement 36
years after you might have
been at another commencement
had your grandfather
not intervened.
Now Mr. Caryl Brown, president
of the Graduate Student
Council, will give
a salute to MIT
from the graduate student body.
Following this, Ms. Ann Chen,
president of the senior class,
will present the class
gift to President Vest.
After Ms. Chen's
presentation, president Vest
will deliver his charge
to the graduates.
BROWN: Thank you Dr. Gray.
In presenting the graduate
students' salute to MIT,
I want to speak in
terms to which students
can most easily relate.
I don't watch Star Trek--
The Next Generation,
so I'll employ
another familiar approach
modeled after Dave Letterman's
Top 10 List.
So without further delay, the
top five reasons for students
to salute MIT.
Number five-- only
at MIT can you
experience the joy and thrill
of turning in a 200-pound thesis
for a quarter ounce receipt.
[LAUGHTER]
Number four-- MIT
supports an approach
to learning and research
that is laid back,
relaxed, and carefree.
[LAUGHTER]
Number three-- MIT continually
strives to break down barriers
and push limits in all areas--
technology, science, diversity,
and tuition cost structures.
Number two-- our campus police
patrols the lows and highs
of this wonderful campus
on which we work and live.
[APPLAUSE]
And the number-one
reason to salute MIT--
we are the premier engineering
and science institution
in the world, not to
mention Sloan is now
ranked ahead of that little
business school up the river.
[CHEERING]
Graduates, when times
get tough out there,
just remember all of the
truly rewarding experiences
and relationships you
have had while at MIT.
They will serve you well.
Congratulations and
good luck always.
[APPLAUSE]
CHEN: I remember the last time
all of us, the class of 1994,
were assembled together.
It was in Kresge Auditorium
during [INAUDIBLE]
of our freshman year.
Former MIT President
Paul Gray told
us to look at the
people seated around us.
He then told us one
out of five of us
wouldn't graduate in four years.
You may have been worried
that you wouldn't graduate.
Or you could have been wondering
which one of your friends
wouldn't graduate.
But I think President Gray made
an impression on most of us.
Today, all of us have made it.
And we should be very proud.
When we entered MIT,
we were a unique class.
We were supposed to be the
smartest class to enter,
since we had the
highest SAT average.
We were the first to
experience pass-fail,
with C being passing and not D.
During our four years at MIT,
we witnessed many changes.
MIT became ranked number four
in US News and World Report,
ahead of both
Caltech and Stanford.
We felt the disappearance of
a mandatory $1,500 meal plan.
We saw the emergence
of two new sororities
and one new fraternity.
We faced the possibility
of getting rid of IAP,
but instead we lengthened
it to a full four weeks.
One safe ride van turned
into two and then four vans.
Our meal plan IDs and dorm keys
merged into student services
cards.
We also observed the
Persian Gulf War.
We witnessed the
abolishment of apartheid
and the election of South
Africa's first black president.
We saw the tearing down
of the Berlin Wall.
We experienced the breakup
of the Soviet Union.
All of these changes
suggest that change is good
and that change is improvement.
We all have the ability to
make changes, whether globally,
nationally, or locally.
And I believe we have a
certain responsibility
to make a difference.
Our first change as an alumni
class is our senior class gift.
All of us have benefited
from past alumni class gifts,
whether they are renovated
classrooms or financial aid
or something else.
And now future classes
will benefit from our gift.
As a class, we have already
raised $43,000 for MIT.
I am pleased to announce
that 24% of our class
has participated in
this year's senior gift,
and 87% of those pledges
are over a five-year period.
The majority of
our classmates have
chosen to have their gift help
fund the senior project, which
involves renovating and
expanding the Stratton Student
Center information desk and
adding to it an enclosed box
office.
I envision the MIT ticket
and information source
becoming a center where
the MIT community can track
major Institute,
community, national,
and international happenings
through a television monitor,
events board, and database.
In addition, students
will be able to pick up
important forms, reserve
[INAUDIBLE] poster and Lobby 10
space, and buy tickets to MIT
events all in the same place.
Class of 1994 graduates, we have
made a worthwhile difference.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
VEST: Thank you, Ms. Chen.
It is a moving experience
to receive for the Institute
a gift from the class
at a moment like this,
especially when we think about
all we've put you through.
We appreciate it very much.
Your gift of new information
booth in the student center
is certainly fitting
for these times.
And I'm sure your
class will in many ways
be racing ahead of most of us
down the emerging information
highway.
And we are very
grateful for the lift
that this gift will give to all
the students who follow you.
Thank you very much.
Once again, we are assembled in
Killian Court, the great court
of MIT, to celebrate
accomplishment, heritage,
and passage.
It may, perhaps, seem
odd that a community
so dedicated to the
future, so permeated
by scientific objectivity,
comes together wearing
strange and colorful
medieval regalia.
But indeed, it is
fitting and seemingly
fulfilling of deep human needs
that such rituals take place.
They remind us of the continuity
through the ages of discovery
and learning, of our role in
an unbroken centuries-old chain
of human accomplishment,
achievements of mind
and of spirit.
But above all, it celebrates
your accomplishments
during your student years.
This is not to say that
you have accomplished
the remarkable
feat of graduating
from MIT on your own, however.
We are surrounded today by
parents, family, friends,
spouses, and children who have
supported and sustained you
through the years.
You will recognize them today
by their smiles, brought
about by their great pride
in your accomplishment
and no doubt by a sense of great
relief to their bank accounts.
Let us then express
our appreciation
to all who have come
to Cambridge today
to join in this
commencement ceremony.
Will you, the graduates, please
rise, turn to your audience,
and give them the applause they
so deeply and richly deserve.
[APPLAUSE]
It is also especially
wonderful to see
the babies and small children
who come to see their mothers
and fathers graduate.
They, too, are welcome.
And as this ceremony stretches
onward, I give each of them
special presidential
approval to comment
upon the proceedings at any time
and in any manner they see fit.
In delivering this
charge, my task
should be to set before you
great principles by which
to live.
Yet in this age of relativism,
as I ponder just which
principles to
disclose to you today,
I recall the statement of
no less a great intellect
than Groucho Marx, who once
said with great conviction,
these are my principles.
And you don't like them, I
have got some other ones.
[LAUGHTER]
So on second thought, I decided
I would bypass the wisdom
and just remind you
of an experience
that we have shared together.
Some of you will recall that
this class is also my class.
On August 31, 1990, we came
together for the first time,
you as MIT's new freshman class,
and I as MIT's new freshman
president.
That moment, which Ann
referred to a moment ago,
standing before 1,100
of the brightest
and most creative young men and
women from around this nation
and around the world, gathered
together in Kresge Auditorium
to begin their education
at MIT, was surely
one of the most
exhilarating of my life.
On that day, we were all
proud to have been selected
to join the ranks of MIT.
We shared the
exhilaration of becoming
part of its intellectual
and creative atmosphere.
We were confident
and eager to get on
with the year's activities.
But to tell the truth, we also
were a little apprehensive
about the less certain
aspects of what lay ahead.
Nonetheless, we knew
that we were all
embarking on the next
stage of a great adventure.
I said to you that day that
I hoped you would accept me
as a member of your class and
trusted that you would allow
me to live and work among you.
I also noted that I looked
forward to one other occasion
when I would stand before
you in a formal setting
and that that
would be in Killian
Court at your graduation
in the spring of 1994.
Well, we made it,
and here we are.
[APPLAUSE]
For all of us, these four
years have been intense.
They seem to have passed
in the twinkling of an eye
and also to have
lasted a lifetime.
We moved through changes in our
internal and external worlds
that were beyond our imagining.
We encountered new
ideas and new people.
We were enriched by what we
learned in these encounters.
Above all, we learned to
couple intellectual rigor
and discipline with
creativity and innovation.
And we gained the
self-confidence
to approach virtually any
challenge that may lie ahead.
And the challenges
before us are great.
His highness, by his
presence here today
and in the thoughts
he has shared with us,
reminded each of us just how
great these challenges are.
We live and work in a rapidly
changing and increasingly
interdependent world society.
It is a world in which new
balances must be struck.
We must resolve the
tensions between competition
and cooperation, between
fragmentation and integration,
between nation and world.
This will take some learning.
We understand well the
value of competition.
We know the value of the rugged
individual and the iconoclast.
But we are just beginning
to learn the value
of cooperation and of teamwork.
Economically,
socially, politically--
if you want to shape a
vibrant and just future,
you must learn to cooperate
as well as to compete.
The message of
cooperation is simple,
but its implementation
is not, for we
seem to have fragmented along
every conceivable fault line,
fragmented by intellectual
discipline, fragmented by race,
fragmented by gender,
fragmented by geography.
In the international arena,
we have stepped back at last
from the superpower standoff.
But we find peace and
stability challenged
by the unleashed forces of
nationalism, ethnic hatred,
and local warfare.
With every such
division, we lose
more of a sense of
our common humanity.
It will not be easy to resolve
our differences and tensions.
But if we are to
build the future we
want for ourselves
and our children,
we must build it together.
We must have a sense
of common purpose.
We must have an integrated,
inclusive view of history.
We must have community.
We must have mutual respect.
We must hold common values
at the deepest levels.
I believe this is
possible because I believe
that the true historical
trend is one of communication,
interaction, and cooperation.
Witness the people
of South Africa
who have at last placed
apartheid behind them
and set off on a
brave, new path.
I do not suggest that we
sweep aside all differences.
Quite the contrary, we thrive
on differences of experience,
culture, and perspective.
As Alfred North Whitehead said
in his 1925 lectures on science
in the modern world,
quote, "Other nations
of different habits
are not enemies.
They are godsends."
This is true whether we speak
of society's professions
or single institutions.
The electrical engineer
and the mechanical engineer
are able to build
systems together
which neither can build alone.
Men and women together create
a balanced discourse and world
view.
Black and white, brown
and yellow, red and tan
create a campus and a nation
far more meaningful and creative
than any could alone.
As you shape the future,
you must respect and cherish
differences, but you must build
common purpose and values.
MIT is an American
institution, and each of you
is a citizen of some nation.
For most of you, that nation is
the United States of America.
But MIT is also an
institution of the world.
And its greatness
derives in large measure
from its cosmopolitan
nature and connections
throughout the world.
The same must be true of you.
Be proud and committed
to your nations,
but also look beyond them.
To shape a future
of greatness, you
must be citizens of the world.
And though this world seems
increasingly less predictable
and less stable, the opportunity
to discover, learn, grow,
and serve has never
been so great.
I am optimistic that
we and especially you
will make the most
of this opportunity.
Why am I optimistic?
We need only look
around ourselves today.
Our faculty and our
students are the reason
for this confidence
and this hope,
because MIT is a place that
helps to shape the future.
Because of our
faculty, MIT is a place
where science advances, where
art thrives, where technology
extends our reach, where thought
leads to new order, where
new modes of
teaching and learning
are invented and put to use.
But the still deeper
reason for optimism is you.
You are unmatched in your
talent, your education,
your sense of service, your
entrepreneurial spirit,
and your basic goodness.
Beyond that, you have had
the remarkable experience
of living and learning
in a truly international,
multicultural community.
And all the while, you have
been setting and meeting
your own highest standards.
With such a legacy, you give us
all great hope for the future.
You will not fail us.
You will not fail that future.
Men and women of MIT, I wish
you Godspeed and the very best
of good fortune.
[APPLAUSE]
GRAY: By virtue of the
authority delegated
to them by the corporation
of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
and on the recommendation
of the faculty,
President Vest will now
present the Bachelor
of Science degrees
and the Bachelor and
Master of Science degrees
awarded simultaneously.
And Provost Wrighton will
present advanced degrees.
The names of the recipients
of Bachelor of Science degrees
and Bachelor and Master
of Science degrees
awarded simultaneously will be
read by the Associate Provost
for Institute Life,
Samuel J. Keyser and Dean
of Undergraduate Education
and Student Affairs Arthur C.
Smith.
The names of the recipients
of the advanced degrees
will be read by the deans
of the five schools.
The first persons
to be recognized
are the class marshals, who
are seated here on the stage.
PRESENTER: Recognition
will now be
given to the officers
of the class of 1994
and the president
and vice president
of the Graduate Student Council,
who are seated on the stage.
Ann Chen, president
of the class of 1994,
is awarded the degree of
Bachelor of Science in biology.
[APPLAUSE]
Catherine L. Downard,
treasurer of the class of 1994,
is awarded the degree
of Bachelor of Science
in aeronautics and astronautics.
[APPLAUSE]
Caryl B. Brown, president of
the Graduate Student Council,
is pursuing dual Master
of Science degrees
through the Leaders for
Manufacturing Program.
[APPLAUSE]
Christopher M.
Gittens, vice president
of the Graduate
Student Council, is
entering the sixth
year of graduate study
in the Department of Chemistry.
He is pursuing the degree
of Doctor of Philosophy.
[APPLAUSE]
PRESENTER: Bachelor
of Science diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of
Architecture and Planning
who have completed the
specified degree requirement.
For Bachelor of Science and
Art and Design, Dalhia O. Ali.
PRESENTER: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of
Architecture and Planning
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
Master of Architecture--
[READING NAMES]
Also a member of the class
of 1994 executive committee.
Bachelor of Science as
recommended by the Department
of Architecture, [INAUDIBLE].
Master of Science in
Architecture Studies,
[INAUDIBLE].
For Bachelor of Science
in Planning, [INAUDIBLE]..
Also Master in City Planning--
[READING NAMES]
For Bachelor of
Science-- diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of Engineering
who have completed the specified
degree requirements.
For Bachelor of Science
in civil engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Building Technology--
[READING NAMES]
For a Bachelor of Science
in Environmental Engineering
Science--
[READING NAMES]
Master in City Planning--
Bachelor of Science
as recommended
by the Department of Civil and
Environmental Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in
Mechanical Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in Urban
Studies and Planning--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Media Arts and Sciences--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science without
specification of field--
[READING NAMES]
Doctor of Philosophy with
all the rights and privileges
pertaining thereto--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the number-one
school of engineering
in the country who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
Master of Science in Civil and
Environmental Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Mechanical Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Materials Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science
in Metallurgy--
[READING NAMES]
Here
Master of Science in Polymers--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in Material
Science and Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: The
following students
are among the first to receive
the Master of Engineering
degree at MIT.
Master of Engineering and
Electrical Engineering
and Computer Science--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science as
recommended by the Department
of Mechanical Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in Electrical
Engineering and Computer
Science--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in Material
Science and Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
as recommended
by the Department of Materials
Science and Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
in Electrical Science
and Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Chemical Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in Chemical
Engineering Practice--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Ocean Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in Naval
Architecture and Marine
Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Naval Architecture
and Marine Engineering, Naval
Construction and Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Ocean Systems Management--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Aeronautics and Astronautics--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Nuclear Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Technology and Policy--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science
in Transportation--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science without
specification of field--
[READING NAMES]
Doctor of Science with all
the rights and privileges
pertaining thereto--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in
Electrical Engineering
and Computer Science--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in Computer
Science and Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Doctor of Philosophy with
all the rights and privileges
pertaining thereto--
[READING NAMES]
For Bachelor of Science
in Chemical Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of
Humanities and Social
Science who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
Master of Science in
Political Science--
[READING NAMES]
Doctor of Philosophy with
all the rights and privileges
pertaining thereto--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science as
recommended by the Department
of Chemical Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
in Ocean Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in
Aeronautics and Astronautics--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be presented to
students in the Sloan School
of Management--
[APPLAUSE]
--who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
Master of Science
in Management--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in
Nuclear Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Bachelor
of Science diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the School of
Humanities and Social
Science who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
Bachelor of Science
in Economics--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
in Political Science--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in
Anthropology Archeology--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in Music--
Bachelor of Science in Writing--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
in Humanities--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in
Humanities and Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in
Humanities and Science--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
in Philosophy--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in Science
Technology in Society--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of science
diplomas will now
be presented to students in
the Sloan School of Management
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
Bachelor of Science in
Management Science--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
diplomas will now
be presented to students
in the School of Science
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
Bachelor of Science
in chemistry--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in Biology--
Bachelor of Science
as recommended
by the Department of Biology--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science in Physics--
Master of Science in
Management of Technology--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
in Cognitive Science--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science in
Operations Research--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
in Earth, Atmospheric,
and Planetary Sciences--
[READING NAMES]
Doctor of Philosophy with
all the rights and privileges
pertaining thereto--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
in Mathematics--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: Advanced
degree diplomas
will now be
presented to students
in the world's premier
school of science
who have completed the
specified degree requirements.
Master of Science in Physics--
[READING NAMES]
Doctor of Philosophy with
all the rights and privileges
pertaining thereto--
[READING NAMES]
Bachelor of Science
in Mathematics
with Computer Science--
[READING NAMES]
The Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institution
and the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
offered joint programs
of education and research
in oceanography and applied
ocean science and engineering.
Dr. John W. Farrington, dean of
graduate studies at the Woods
Hole Oceanographic
Institution, is here
to participate with
Provost Wrighton
in awarding the
following joint degrees.
Master of Science in
Mechanical Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Master of Science
in Oceanography--
[READING NAMES]
Master of science in
Oceanographic Engineering--
[READING NAMES]
Doctor of Philosophy with
all the rights and privileges
pertaining thereto--
[READING NAMES]
PRESENTER: This is the moment
we've been waiting for.
Advanced degree
diplomas will now
be presented to students in
the Whitaker College of Health
Sciences and Technology who have
completed the specified degree
requirements.
Master of Science
in Toxicology--
[READING NAMES]
Doctor of Philosophy with
all the rights and privileges
pertaining thereto--
[READING NAMES]
[APPLAUSE]
GRAY: I speak now particularly
to members of the class of 1944
who were part of the procession
and who are sitting here
to the left of the stage.
In accordance with
our traditions,
members of the
50th reunion class
are participating
in the ceremonies.
This class, the class of
1944, entered the Institute
before the United States
entered World War II
and may have had the
expectation not held
by later wartime classes
of a normal completion
of their undergraduate degrees.
For most members of the class
of 1944, this was not to be.
The records of the
Institute indicate
that of all the wartime classes
at MIT, the class of 1944
may well have experienced
the greatest disruption.
Most who entered with this class
did not receive their diplomas
until after the war, if at all.
Many did not return
from the war.
Today as you return to
Tech for your 50th reunion,
we extend a special
welcome to you.
May your participation
in these commencement
ceremonies recognize and
reaffirm your special place
in the history
and family of MIT.
[APPLAUSE]
It is now my pleasure to
introduce Mr. Richard A.
Jacobs, the Chief Marshal,
who will greet the graduates.
Mr. Jacobs is a member
of the class of 1956
and is currently
serving as president
of the MIT Association
of Alumni and Alumnae.
JACOBS: Thank you, Dr. Gray.
May 27 is one of the
longest days in the year--
14 hours and 58 minutes, dawn
to dusk, from today's newspaper.
I do not intend to
make it any longer.
[CHEERING]
Let me leave you with one more
simple equation to consider,
adopt, and use in your
continuing quest for knowledge.
Lombardi's axiom states, "The
quality of a person's life
is directly proportional
to their commitment
to excellence."
Today, you take a major
step in that commitment.
Remember this day.
Look once more around
this great court.
It belongs to you.
Take pride.
You are a most uncommon group.
Keep in contact.
Come back often.
Help others to achieve what
you have accomplished and will
realize later in life.
Now join me and the
distinguished members
of the 50th and 25th reunion
classes of 1944 and 1969
as we applaud today's
graduates and welcome
into that most select
company of men and women
who are MIT's
alumni and alumnae.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
GRAY: The 128th
Commencement Exercises
of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
are now concluded.
[CHEERING]
Please join now the
Backlogs Quartet,
a splinter group of
former Logarithms,
in singing the school song.
The stage assembly and the
graduates will please rise.
[MUSIC - "ARISE ALL YE OF MIT"]
BACKLOGS QUARTET: Arise all ye
of MIT, in loyal fellowship.
The future beckons unto ye
and life is full and rich.
Arise and raise
your glass on high.
Tonight shall ever
be a memory that
will never die for ye of MIT.
Thy sons and daughters, MIT,
return from far and wide.
And gather here once more to
be renourished by thy side.
And as we raise our glasses high
to pledge our love for thee,
we join all those of days
gone by in praise of MIT.
[MUSIC - "TAKE ME BACK TO TECH"]
I wish that I were back again
at Tech on Boylston Street,
dressed in my dinky uniform,
so dapper and so neat.
I'm crazy after calculus.
I never had enough.
It was hard to be
dragged away so young.
It was horribly, awfully tough.
Hurrah for technology,
'ology, 'ology, oh.
Glorious old technology,
Back in the days that
were free from care
in the 'ology varsity shop, with
nothing to do but analyze air
in anemometrical top.
Or the differentiation of
the trigonometric powers,
the constant pi
that made me sigh,
in those happy days of ours.
Hurrah for technology,
'ology, ology, oh.
Glorious old technology,
'ology, 'ology, oh.
Take me back on a special train
to that glorious Institute.
I yearn for the inspiration
of a technological toot.
I'd shun the quizzical physical
prof, the chapel, and all that,
but how I'd love to go
again on a scientific bat.
Hurrah for technology,
'ology, 'ology, oh.
Glorious old technology,
M-A-S-S-A-C-H-U-S-E-T-T-S
I-N-S-T-I-T-U-T-E-O-F-T-E
but C-H-N-O-L-O-G
and Y comes after G.
The Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
Hey!
[CHEERING]